çb a voting is still open it opened last
Thursday it was extended from Thursday
at 11:59 p.m. Eastern to Saturday at
11:59 p.m. Eastern that happened before
the world turned upside down and now
that the world is upside down MDS it's a
no-brainer to me that the players should
vote YES on this cba because i believe
if they vote known if they reject this
the owners are going to first of all
engage in no further negotiations until
they can assess the total damage to
their overall business interests from
the coronavirus crisis and the economic
downturn sparked by it and then after
they're able to fully understand how
badly it hurts them that's when they
craft a new plan for negotiating with
the players and making as much money
back that they lost elsewhere from their
football teams so the players are going
to get screwed the next time around
because when push comes to shove a
strikes not gonna work a lock outs not
gonna last into football season because
the players don't want to miss game
checks they don't want to miss games
once those are gone they never come back
that's the reality and I see where it's
heading right and I'm convinced and na
if you want to say I'm carrying water
for the NFL I don't care I'm convinced
that if this offer isn't accepted given
everything that's happened over the past
week it's not coming back and I mean if
the NFL owners had a chance to pull it
off the table right now I think they
would that's why the players who haven't
voted need to vote yes and that's why
the NFL PA needs to reconsider its
refusal that players change their votes
because from the people I've talked to
I'd say a very high percentage of the
guys who voted no would now vote yes
recognizing the world has changed and
they were to take this deal while they
still can
yeah and it's especially true of the
middle and lower classes of players the
guys who are making the league minimum
or near the league minimum and the guys
who maybe they're making more than the
lead
if they make the team but they're not
sure that they'll be making the team
there's a lot in the CBA a - like for
those players because it increases the
minimum salary and it adds spots on the
roster - roster spots and to practice
squad spots so that's more jobs
available for NFL teams so maybe you're
right around player number 53 or 54 on
your team you might not have a job on a
53 man roster you might have one on a 55
man roster or maybe you're around player
number 63 and you might just barely be
making the practice squad but with two
more practice squad spots in addition to
two more roster spots you've got a
better chance of making the practice
squad if you don't make the active
roster so those are a lot of players who
I think are going to be very
disappointed in how it turns out if this
CBA gets turned down and and look if you
are one of the the last 64 guys cut from
a regular-season roster at the end of
the preseason or one of the 64 guys
struggling to make a practice squad at
the end of the preseason you're gonna be
looking at yourself that's 128 players
who will be out of work who wouldn't be
and those players especially I think
they've got to be ready to vote for this
CBA and they've gotta understand that
even if I think I'm good enough that
I'll definitely make the roster I don't
know that for sure I don't know if I'm
the second string tight end and my
coaches are telling me hey you did a
great job this year we're excited about
bringing you back I don't know that
they're not gonna sign up a rookie tight
end who wowed them in the preseason and
then decide to keep only two tight ends
you just don't know that so unless you
are one of the guys with a guaranteed
contract or or you're a player who is so
good that you
just know you are going to make this
roster you just you are really playing
with fire if you decide to vote no yeah
I agree with you and the problem is a
lot of the guys who should be voting YES
based upon their own individual
interests they were influenced by guys
like JJ Watt Russell Wilson Aaron
Rodgers and voted no and it would be
nice if one of those guys number one
understood that the circumstances have
changed and number two would go to
Twitter and say hey you know what guys
before the world turned upside down I
was a no now that the world is upside
down and this offer is still on the
table I'm a yes because circumstances
have changed and here's the example that
I came up with kind of on the fly during
PFT live or earlier day I'm gonna try it
on UMTS and see if you buy this this is
unprecedented to have an opportunity
where you can still accept a deal when
at the time the deal was made the world
was one way and at the time you're
accepting the deal the world is a
different way and speaking of the world
the movie was called the world according
to GARP and it starred Robin Williams
and Glenn Close and it was 1981 82 ish
GARP played by Robin Williams was
looking at a house with his wife and as
they were getting ready to decide on
whether to buy the house a plane flew
into it and Robin Williams reaction was
we'll take it and his where he was like
what the hell are you talking about he
said well the house has been pre
disaster there's no way another plane is
ever gonna fly into this house and I
thought in that example because this is
the equivalent of the seller and the
buyer ready to do a deal the buyer has
made a firm offer on the house
irrevocable that's the offer and during
the window that the seller has to make a
decision a plane flies into the house
well at that point the seller is saying
hell yes I'm selling the house because
if the seller says no the buyers offer
is off the table it's never coming back
and it sounds unrealistic because
something like that never happens right
well right except in this context with
the CBA it's happened there's an offer
on the table that's been signed off on
by ownership and the world has changed
and frankly I'm surprised that the
league hasn't tried to to yank the offer
off the table I
I think that there are plenty of owners
right now that are itching for the NFLPA
to say no here and when it came out
Saturday from Jeromy Fowler of ESPN that
some owners are hoping that the players
vote no it felt like a weird kind of
double reverse psychology like mid to do
we want him to vote like if we trying to
get him to really vote yes are we trying
to get him to really vote no who knows
but the reality now is the owners are
gonna yank that offer off the table and
they're gonna run away and hide and
they're gonna wait to see what the total
tally is of what is currently happening
and then the players will get an offer
that reflects an attempt to use their
football business to earn back money
that they lost elsewhere guaranteed and
I can't help it if guys in their mid 20s
late 20s early 30s haven't experienced
enough in the business world to
understand that's how it works because
they've been football players their
whole life but guys that's how it works
and as I said yesterday and I'll say it
again if my son came to me he's 23 and
if he was in the NFL and he said what
should I do
I wouldn't even need to read the deal
but wait they offered you this deal
before the world turned upside down now
the world's upside down take the damn
deal yeah no doubt about it and we have
seen just in the last couple of weeks
the stock market is absolutely tanking
and obviously that means a lot of NFL
owners have lost a lot of their wealth
and I think they would probably wish
they had been a little more cautious and
safe with their other source of wealth
which is their football team and and
maybe not offering such a long-term deal
during such unpredictable times so these
are very unpredictable times and I think
that long-term security were like a
10-year CBA be a pretty good thing to
have right now yeah absolutely and
Thomas Moore stead who's a member the
executive committee and he's the Saints
punter he took to Twitter yesterday to
explain this is certainty during
uncertain times and the world once again
has changed and I wish I wish some of
these guys who were proponents of voting
no would come out and say hey you know
what
it is a very different world
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports